transgender issues should trans women be
included in feminist conversations how
about in women's spaces yes they're
women
what's the question
trans women or women
um
so I I want to come at this from the
position of an athlete oh Jesus um so so
I play semi-pro basketball Semi-Pro
volleyball so when it comes to like
athletic spaces I don't think that trans
women should be allowed into athletic
spaces because I don't think it's a fair
um I think as female athletes we work so
incredibly hard for the little
opportunity there is in women's sports
would this be a barrier like this
there's no barrier there's less
opportunity in some Industries there's
less it's not no no no it's based on the
market okay hold on hold on guys okay so
again we work very hard for the little
opportunity there is in the space
because we're not as entertaining as the
men sorry we're just not and so it's
like you're going to take the little
opportunity that we're given and the
problem is like
we can't compete we can't like I'm six
foot if I go up against a six foot guy
and I play basketball with him he's
gonna body me and what happens
even if I have years more of training
and so it's like you're taking away the
little opportunity that we're given and
we all work so hard for and you're just
giving it back to biological guys it's
like this will be the end of women's
sports have you tried confidence Eli
hold on sorry confidence can't make me
bench with a guy benches
so hostile she's sharing and confidence
assistant
your own experiences and your own
existence And yet when a woman is
sitting here telling you I feel as
though this is unfair and this is
compromising and the situation is not
helping women you guys are like but when
you're like I'm a black person that did
this this and this then it's valid and
fair and viable Eli I want to give you
the chance to respond so this is
basically a joke of a talking point
everyone has biological advantages in
sports how tall are you five eleven and
a half I'm tall I'm five foot eight I am
a trans woman I you would crush me you
would absolutely bone density wrist
strength
muscle density you can't switch those
yeah exactly you would crush me but also
Eli you would never play at the level
that Pearl plays because you would never
get there so let me give you a few more
examples here too so Michael Phelps
produced more lactic acid in his body
which caused him to swim better than any
of his competitors this was widely
celebrated and nobody contested it now
just this is in a performance-enhancing
hormone
so we all have different bodies and I'm
not saying that trans women who aren't
on hormones should participate but there
are I mean every major medical and every
major sports organization agrees that
trans women who have been on hormones
for between one and three years
depending on the organization have the
same competitive abilities that's that
did the study that you're referencing
had like seven people participated
several different studies I'm a trans
woman and a researcher it's getting
personal I don't want it to be
personally live in this space where
we're told that our opinions don't count
because they're not the right kind of
opinions and we're constantly shouted
over and talked over regardless of what
we look like because there's one group
in society that basically takes
precedence and it's frustrating so yeah
of course it's it's it's frustrating
because when we try to talk about it we
get shouted down we get told to be quiet
we we get we get spooking down too as
well so there's hostility there for
plenty of women let's try to make this
an opportunity to speak literally a
white woman from Australia you live in a
bubble and you're pissed that voices
that have been silenced forever finally
can be heard that's why they have the
boys because they speak up okay we're
having a conversation about transgender
women participating in sports and I
wanted to allow more people to
participate Jordan I wanted to hear from
you so I am not a professional athlete
the closest thing I have ever done to
anything athletic was I used to do
competitive show choir when I was
younger and
um I don't feel really qualified to make
carp long statements about whether or
not trans women should compete in every
kind of sport and I understand that that
is kind of
that's a hard pill to swallow and for me
my first inclination is to approach
everything through a lens of inclusivity
but at the same time I also can't speak
accurately to every kind of sport and
the different things that go into it so
I really think in these instances the
decisions are best left up to the
professional governing bodies that
dictate these particular Sports I just
feel like
in places as an ally in places where
there's no understanding we can just
respect and not really like our opinions
don't [ __ ] matter
Eli saw you nodding your head over there
several times
um
so
um this is more than about sports this
is about
um Freedom like free and equal
participation for transgender people in
social life and the right sees this as a
socially acceptable way to begin to
remove trans people from different
engagements in our society so it does
just start with sports or bathrooms or
locker rooms something that they find is
more acceptable and then at this point
they start to move into education
getting trans teachers fired Banning
trans books this is a route that is very
effective because it's seen as more
acceptable
but it's also overlooking a lot of major
details like I mean do you all know how
many trans women have won national
titles
one too many one Julia Thomas is the
only one if we're too many if women's
sports were actually going to end in
some way
um I mean it's just not happening
wouldn't you think there would be more
trans women in sports when the majority
of states do allow trans women full
participation International titles zero
no Global titles have ever been won by a
trans woman
I want to move on to a different topic I
want to talk about me too and sort of
this social movement that we've lived
through we're living through right now
what is the state of feminism sort of in
this post metoo era
or imposed me too all right
tell me
um
sorry I got distracted by the B2 part
because I was like post me too wow like
no one's getting like sexually harassed
anymore
we did it guys we solved the problem
about that World
um no I I think obviously the state of
feminism is very much reflected right in
this room but me too for me right in a
particular context means something for
different people it's a different
experience for different people and in
my culture and in my community we're
still working through that there is no
post me too right we're still working
through how do we have these tough
conversations how do we teach not just
you know women but everyone about
consent what does consent look like what
does that look like in our community
what does that not look like right all
those things that I think it's still
very complicated but I think it starts
at the level of community right of like
how do we have these conversations
around consent Sydney I saw your head up
so uh when the metoo thing was unfolding
I was initially like great I love the
idea of women being able to speak out
what's been really disappointing I
suppose for me post me to is as we're
calling it is that and especially as
someone who's sort of on the right wing
of Politics as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible